AND NOW A HIP-HOP NEWSBREAK
WITH CHUCK TAYLOR
GOOD EVENING,
I'M CHUCK TAYLOR.
IT'S BEEN A VERY BUSY DAY
IN THE NEWS.
A LOT OF THINGS HAVE HAPPENED.
A STATEN ISLAND MAN IS LISTED
IN STABLE CONDITION TONIGHT
AFTER A BRUTAL ASSAULT
BY RAPPER METHOD MAN
FOLLOWING AN ARGUMENT.
THE VICTIM ADDRESSED THE PRESS
EARLIER TODAY.
IT WAS TORTURE.
STRAIGHT TORTURE, SON.
FIRST HE PUT MY NUTS
ON THE DRESSER.
IT WAS CRAZY--JUST MY NUTS.
AND THEN HE BANGED THEM (BLEEP)
WITH A SPIKED BAT, LIKE "BOW!"
[audience groans]
AND THEN, HE SEWED
MY ASSHOLE SHUT.
KEPT FEEDING ME
AND FEEDING ME AND FEEDING ME!
THIS ALL TOOK PLACE IN
THE SLUMS OF SHAOLIN.
THERE WAS THE RZA, THE GZA,
OL' DIRTY BASTARD,
RAEKWON THE CHEF, U-GOD,
INSPECTAH DECK,
AND OF COURSE, THE METHOD MAN.
THE VICTIM ALSO SAID THAT
AT ONE POINT
DURING THE ALTERCATION,
METHOD MAN PUT A HANGER
ON THE STOVE
AND LEFT IT
FOR, LIKE, 40 MINUTES
AND THEN HE STUCK IT
IN HIS ASS REAL SLOW.
LIKE, "SSS..."
AT THIS POINT, METHOD MAN
IS STILL AT LARGE,
SO STAY TUNED TO NEWS CHANNEL 3
FOR THIS AND OTHER STORIES.
I'M CHUCK TAYLOR.